the University of California Irvine is
apologizing to nearly 500 students whose
admission offers were revoked the school
accepted around 40,000 first year and
transfer students more than 7,000 said
they would enroll as freshmen that is
hundreds more than the university had
planned on the Vice Chancellor of
admission said in a statement for those
who felt ignored or mistreated I
sincerely apologize Tony de Cobo is here
with how the students are responding to
being shut out Tony good morning good
morning UC Irvine canceled the admission
offers just two months before classes
began nearly 200 students have filed
Appeals while others are left scrambling
to find another college still willing to
take them this late in the summer my
heart literally sink like right when I
like first saw it emily roche says she
was shocked to learn UC Irvine had
withdrawn her offer of admission the
University told her it didn't receive
her transcripts I didn't really
understand exactly why they would do
this to me because I fulfilled all the
requirements I turned in everything on
time
Irvine says it can withdraw admissions
offers for a variety of reasons
including not maintaining a 3.0 senior
year GPA getting a D or F in a class or
missing deadlines for submitting test
scores and transcripts
there is no student who has been
admitted and has met all the
requirements that is not being
accommodated this fall
Thomas Parham the Vice Chancellor in
charge of admissions says the University
took a harder line this year enforcing
its deadlines he admits the high demand
for spots in the incoming class was
likely a factor UC Irvine ranked number
9 on the US News and World Report list
of top public schools received a record
104 thousand admission applications this
year the incoming class is about 800
students larger they need expected
certainly want to be able to examine how
the numbers played out and whether or
not we could have been more forthcoming
in our communications in all our vine
rescinded 499 admissions offers Parham
encouraged those revoked erroneously to
appeal less than 100 have been
reinstated so far Roche hopes she
join them it's it's just an unfortunate
situation of being and like no one
deserves that not even my greatest
enemies and there have of course been
admissions issues at other University of
California campuses in 2009 UC San Diego
mistakenly sent welcome emails to about
29,000 students who had been rejected
earlier this year Harvard revoked
admission to at least ten students who
shared vulgar messages on Facebook but
you know in this case it's not about
behavior it's not about bad grades it's
about missing deadlines for paperwork
and for so many young people who sweat
and stress over the college application
process to get a letter that says you
get in and then to get another one and
says sorry we're rescinding it that's
absolutely heartbreaking and devastating
absolutely a lot of angry parents I
imagine this a lot of it so we're not to
be the obligation of the college that
screws up like this what about what
should be what their obligation for
screwing well the college is at its
liberty to set deadlines and if you miss
them to revoke your admissions uh I
think read the fine print going forward
if you're a college student or you want
to be one Tony thank you